les enfants des questions les parents
ont dit janyk ids mon nouveau podcast
qui répond aux questions des enfants
disponible seulement sur l'isr si je
vous dis le roi des fruits vous me
répondez la pomme de fait c'est le fruit
le plus consommé en france devant la
banane et l' orange mais si je vous dis
le fruit préféré des roues réponse la
poire ce fruit à plein de choses
étonnantes à nous raconter alors je me
suis longtemps demandé s'il fallait
parler du fruit ou des recettes qui sont
élaborés à partir du fruit et finalement
j'ai coupé la poire en deux ce sera un
peu des deux suivez-moi
[Musique]
la poire vient de chine où elle était
déjà cultivé il ya près de six mille ans
elle a ensuite progressivement gagné
l'europe où la culture des poiriers est
attestée depuis au moins 2004 changeant
ainsi aujourd'hui on classe toutes les
variétés de poires en deux grandes
catégories les poires asiatiques et les
poires européenne les premières comme
celle ci une machine qui vient de chine
sont issus des descendants des premiers
poiriers sauvages et ont une chair
plutôt 30 quand un peu comme celle des
pommes d'ailleurs celle-ci ressemble à
une pomme les secondes et les poires
européennes viennent quant à elle d'une
même espèce le poirier commun que son
petit nom pyrrhus commune vi la chair
est tendre et juteuse alors une poire
c'est d'abord un régal pour les yeux ça
va du jaune de la guyot à la williams
rouge en passant par le vertendre de
labatt le bronze de la général leclerc
ou encore le verre bronze de la
conférence au passage cette dernière
doit son nom au prix qu'elle a remporté
à la conférence nationale britannique de
la poire en 1885 ben ali dont il ya à
boire et à manger et comme on dit pas
mal toutes ces variétés présente autant
de différences de textures et de saveurs
chacune a son identité debout n'est des
sélections fait depuis des centaines
d'années et encore très récemment
la dernière en date s'appelle engis
granger lice à l'époque de son
inscription au catalogue des variétés en
1998 elle est née dans les vergers des
chercheurs de l'inra l'institut national
de recherche pour l'agriculture et
l'environnement d'un croisement entre la
doyenne et le comice est la doyenne et
divers enfin un croisement façon de
parler les chercheurs ont mélangé 12
variétés de poires effet poussé 11000
poirier avant de la sélectionner son nom
combine le lieu de sa naissance angers
avec le lis l'emblème des rois de france
on dit que la poire était le fruit
préféré des rois de louis xiv en
particulier il n'aimait pas seulement
son goût il adorait aussi sa texture
normal à la fin de sa vie le roi soleil
n'avait plus de dents et comme à
l'époque il n'y avait pas de couronne
enfin je veux dire pour cacher la misère
dans sa bouche le roi se les étaient
toutes fait arracher et devaient se
débrouiller sans dans ces conditions
vous en conviendrez il était plus facile
de croquer une poire qu'une pomme ou une
oie par ailleurs les poires ont
l'avantagé de pousser presque toute
l'année ce qui donnait à louis xiv deux
bonnes raisons pour apprécier ce fruit
il y a les poires d'été comme la guye
all williams qui existe aussi en jaune
et les poires d'automne et d'hiver tels
que la brée ardiles alexandrine la
commiss la passe crazannes celles d'été
doivent se récolter mur et se déguste et
rapidement si vous tombez sur un poirier
plein de poires et que vous avez le
droit de vous servir saisissent saison
une tournée là d'un quart de tour si
elle se détache de l'arbre c'est qu'elle
est mûr sur les étals la poire d'été
doit être souple autour du pédoncule et
celui ci doit être bien attaché aux
fruits et les variétés d'automne et
d'hiver se récolte à partir de mi
septembre alors qu'elles ne sont pas
encore mûrs après un passage au froid
obligatoire pour qu'elles puissent
poursuivre leur maturation elle arrive
sur les étals il faut alors les choisir
bien ferme
cal continuer à mûrir finalement en
france en alternant les variétés et bien
on peut déguster des poires du mois de
juillet au mois de mai suivant et donc
les cuisines à toutes les sauces ça ça
sent la cuisine on peut bien sûr croquer
la poire nature au dessert ou goûters ou
préférer une compote de poires du jus de
poires des poires au sirop ou même à la
tarte aux poires personnellement j'ai
dit il ya aussi et la fameuse poire
belle-hélène créer sans doute en 1864 au
moment de la sortie de l'opéra bouffe la
belle hélène ce dessert consiste à
éplucher une poire en conservant son
pédoncule à la peau chez c'est-à-dire
l'accueillir dans un mélange de sucre et
d'eau puis à l'année n'a pris de
chocolat chaud et à la servir accompagné
d'une glace à la vanille il y a aussi
les poires tapées vous connaissez c'est
une recette de touraine dans la région
d'azay-le-rideau célèbre pour son
château cette tradition des poires
tapées remonte au moyen âge au xième
siècle elle permet de conserver les
fruits longtemps en les desséchant les
poires les peluches et rangés dans des
caissettes grillage et puis enfourner
plusieurs jours dans un four à bois elle
se déshydrate puis sont aplaties avec
une sorte de presse les poires tapées
peuvent alors se déguster tel quel ou
alors réhydrater dans un sirop du vin de
loire par exemple où je m'en tape très
bien une et vous quelle est votre
recette préférée dites le moi en
commentaire allez raconte nous encore de
paix et d'espoir quand je vois que le
prince de motordu est passée par là
la poire a donné son nom à un instrument
utilisé en médecine pour le nettoyage
des oreilles par exemple daumier le
célèbre illustrateur du 19e siècle elle
a utilisé pour caricaturer louis
philippe et puis à la fin des années
1970 début des années 1980 elle a aussi
inspiré des publicitaires pour faire la
promotion d'un modèle de voiture la
renault 14 j'en ai conduit une fois
alors la pêche que j'ai arrêté jane
turner 3e prunes c'est aussi le nom
d'une figure de gymnastique par la fois
directement mais l'arbre sur lequel elle
pousse le poirier
je préfère faire le poireau je savais
bien qu'on allait finir par se fendre la
poire allez à bientôt les épis curieuse
et les épis curieux et si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
une machine qui vient de chine à demain
je ne sais variété présente autant de
texture j'en prends
[Applaudissements]